New York Jets the New York Jets
presumably a sports team of some
sort I mean I've heard of all the big
ones does that they are
[Applause]
they we'll get five suggestions then
we'll drop a beat do a freestyle rap
we'll come to this little uh corner of
the room first suggestion number one
what would you like a freestyle rap
about did you put a hand up yes so
polite
sir corn corn immediately violating the
first rule
unless you mean the the ones on your
feet
perhaps that's the only way to get out
of this without seeming like a a
Dullard are you from a corn producing
state I not no you just think it's very
funny to diminish one of America's great
pastimes agricultural products uh and
cultural history what is it about corn
you find so demeaning and laughable sir
I've got some Ians over there who will
take you to
task what is it about corn what are we
focusing on about this corn come on
so versatile so versatile good I mean
you were trying to say the word
versatile and you couldn't but that's
all right it's got three syllables he
made it have one and seven at the same
time corn and it's versatility the
versatility of corn that sounds like a a
University dissertation that would come
out of Kansas front middle of the show
what would you like a wrap about New
York Jets the New York Jets presumably a
sports team of some
sort I mean I've heard of all the big
ones does that are they are
[Applause]
they did did I just accidentally burn
the New York chat my gosh I roasted
something without knowing what it was
that was where the power came from um
presumably then a soccer
team no cuz if people
don't no no there's there's the Nicks
and there's the the the other
[Applause]
ones the football team the New York Jets
they the Giants and the Jets the Giants
and the Jets oh I've heard of the Giants
though you lied two in one city oh
that's all right is it
cool are they
[__] not they're doing all right now
okay the New York Jets it'll be a very
short portion of the rap back of the
room what you want to rap about
Christmas said mermaids and Christmas
trees we'll do a mermaids Christmas tree
perfectly combined let's come to this
kind of uh corner here what do you want
to wrap out gender reveal gender reveals
love you have you got one coming up soon
this man apparently does sir you what
are you hoping for um gender reveals uh
what's what's your favorite type of
gender reveal what mechanism by which
the gender is
revealed you said you said golf you did
you say forest
fire that did happen didn't it they they
did a gender reveal and it set fire to
to millions of Acres it really was quite
sad but you know beautiful baby girl
ni made up for it and then this this
corner here what would you like a wrap
about Pearl Harbor Pearl
Harbor I have heard of that
one okay so we have corn and its
versatility we have a mermaid Christmas
tree we have the New York Jets we have
gender reveal for fires and of course
Pearl Harbor I should who who said that
over there hello there I mean I can't
see how old are you my friend how old
are you 26 26 okay cool that's all right
I guess you know with more distance you
know just good to know what are you
Japanese no
um I just want to know which angle he's
coming from with
that usually the Japanese at Pearl
Harbor the angle was straight down and
uh you laughed at it just before
okay oh you you've mixed it up look at
that well this is a freestyle as I said
a r made up on the spot Bas and tell on
your suggestions give it up for the band
who are making up this
beat 26 long time before he was born
Pearl Harbor coming down thinking about
corn you would maybe talk to your father
you'd rather move on to this cause
yourself a pava you couldn't say it
properly not of your proclivity be more
specific you like the versatility I'd be
stuck in corn with the butter in if I'm
in the kitchen I'm like bring my mother
in she's incredible I'm in such luck she
comes from corn producers she knows how
to shock never say [__] that be dising
my mom I walk into the larger all the
corn is gone I say this is odd I just
went to the shops did the job brought it
back all the corn on the cop it was
amazing that's a maze pun you get it see
your maze that's the lenan name son I
know more about corn than you do get the
varietal yeah I'm really into Maybe get
the husk separate the wheat from the
chaff that's a different crop but I'll
be bringing it back you never thought
you get so much laughs I'm coming over
here in the water but not a bath I look
down there distorts when I see a pretty
mermaid lady Under the Sea it's not aial
cuz she's like 14 but at Christmas time
she'd be wishing under the tree she's
like look at this it goes so well not
Spruce Pine or fur but she got some
Coral sadly the Coral's bleaching all
the vibrant color it starts leeching now
it's just white and on top gets a wish
of course a mermaid Christmas tree a
star fish with the five limbs I be
asking them flounder fish swimming
around and Sebastian they got the gifts
there under the water also some little
wreckage that our report was found there
from the Japanese Plains they were going
down kamakazi there in flames it's what
made America enter the war it was
happening this time like December they
said the date will live in infamy the
Japanese emperor had it in in for these
American guys they were just chilling on
the battleships they were like this is
so lovely then the battle hits and
that's genuinely nothing to laugh about
planes coming from the sky they were
screaming and Shout they go down the
worst you can get a plane kind of like
the New York Jets this bunch of jets I
never heard at all try it with the
Giants that's the real football the Jets
sadly near or far ironically they flew
under my radar we connect these are they
winning are they doing well is it boy
girl yeah you know we're going to tell
we just pull this tiny firework did we
put it properly no when it went berserk
it shoots off into the trees and the
branches luckily we got our aners whole
black smoke in the forest we admire but
we saw it was a baby girl there in the
fire it starts coming up we should have
stopped and thought pink smoke coming up
and now we report we're really glad we
found it was a baby girl there even
though we murdered like a thousand
bears
yeah you guys are lovely thank you very
much man name first Turner good night
goodbye